I want to explain something to you that
not many people really understand I want
to talk about the law of attraction
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
seven Carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back
it lacked
a belief in yourself you watch these
videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to attract success in
2020 also if you want to have more
confidence motivation and self-love
check out my 254 series they're free the
link to join under description below I
was reminded this morning no big
question I'm often asked how do you
eliminate theatre from your life what we
kind of understand you we're treating
our life for our goals literally trading
our life so I started to study myself I
found most people don't know who they
are they really don't okay let's take it
off with rule number one
understand the law of attraction I want
to explain something to you
that not many people really understand I
want to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's gonna go
down it's never gonna go back up it's
gonna go down that is law of gravity
anything heavier than earth is attracted
towards the center of the world well the
law of attractions always working now
how does it work well I use a diagram to
explain the mind now let this circle
represent your mind and let this little
circle here represent your body now I
want you to think of this for a moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that'll keep you
thinking for the next twenty years when
you move out of it the body does not
stop moving if you go to a funeral
parlor and pick up the remains and look
at it you will see it moving and if it
wasn't moving how would it ever change
best you move into your body and you
will move up and it's how you use your
mind that's gonna dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me you have an
imaginary line right across here and
that separates the conscious mind from
the subconscious mind now the
subconscious mind has been programmed
when you were a little baby
this is the way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there and all the energy
that went in there when you were just a
little baby form something called a
paradigm now a paradigm is information
it's a multitude of habits you are the
product of your environment but prior to
that you are the product of a genetic
strain that goes back for generations
now I'm going to say that the paradigm
is X type energy now you've got the
ability here on a conscious level to
think and you can think anything you
want to think and as you think you build
ideas there's a power that's flowing
into your consciousness it never stops
it flows to and through you you can
actually photograph this power leaving
you it flows to and through you now as
it flows in you will start thinking and
you'll probably think XY plus therefore
you're going to be in an X type
vibration and that will produce X type
results now it's the results you want to
change and to change the results you're
gonna have to change what you attract to
see the thoughts that you think control
the vibration that you're in vibration
is nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rest we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
bodies in
that dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract you attract
energy that's in harmony with you you
attract people that are in harmony with
you
you see everything operates on
frequencies there's a infinite number of
frequencies but you and I operate on the
frequency just like a radio station does
and the only music you can attract is
the music that is tuned into the
vibration you're in now it's the
paradigm that has been controlling the
vibration you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you really
change the paradigm and if you don't
change the paradigm nothing happens now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we will do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a Y
type thought which is totally different
than the X type conditioning it isn't
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type done the paradigm will kick it out
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in then the
vibration areas going to dictate what
you attract people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
black and limitation it has nothing to
do with this what's going on here this
is your educated mind and you could
gather all kinds of information have you
ever wondered why some people have such
an educated mind they have degrees
coming right off the end of their
business card but it doesn't show up in
their results why they're done
the law of attraction you've got to
change this you've got to change the
vibration you're in and your whole world
changes listen in 1961 a man gave me
this book and he said do exactly what I
tell you he was giving me why type ideas
it caused an enormous amount of
discomfort but I did exactly what he
said and you know something my income
went from four thousand one hundred and
seventy five thousand a year and then I
took it over a million it took me nine
and a half years to figure out what
happened this is what I'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here now
I have a special bonus clip from Bob on
how to believe that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question today I'd
love to know what do you think of this
style of video just one longer clip
instead of a whole bunch of different
people let me know give me your thoughts
you love it you want more you hate it
you never want to see it again prove
down the comments below and if you made
it this far I want to celebrate you
thank you so much give me a hashtag
believe in the comments as well you tell
yourself a lie often enough you're gonna
start to believe it and way around 1900
William James said believe and your
belief will create the fact it's got to
be believed you've got to believe it and
if there's no belief it ain't going to
happen
see when you believe it you're encased
in the idea you fuse with the idea and
that makes all kinds of things happen
when you believe it there's no quitting
you never quit it doesn't matter what
happens you don't quit quitting is never
an option I the people that quit they
never really bought into the idea in the
first place see you've got it you you
get it on three levels the second you
think of something you've got it
intellectually when you get emotionally
involved you've got it on a spiritual or
emotional level well then that expresses
itself through the body body's just an
instrument of your mind and so
when you're really buying into it you
literally fuse with it Nevel said you
fuse with it and this causes all kinds
of things to happen you're dealing with
electronics you're dealing with energy
like the second you think something
that's all you need see you live on
frequencies you think on frequencies
your phone operates on frequencies and
it's like magic you're you're in Romania
right I'm in Toronto yes if I've got
your number on my phone I could take a
picture something hit it like that
you've got it in Romania simultaneous
with me sending it because when you get
into the mind there isn't any time or
space it's just immediate yeah well the
you're living on frequencies now when
you think of something what you've done
is you've flipped your brain onto a
higher frequency
the very fact you can see it is all the
proof you need to know you could get it
what you have to do is raise your level
of consciousness to that frequency and
then you will attract whatever is on
that frequency all the good you need to
manifest the idea if you want Bob
proctors top fifty rules for success
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I don't
think you determine what your purpose is
I think you discover what your purpose
is there's a difference
determining indicates deciding